did he know absolutely categorically
that there was a line of demarcation
that desean watson said you know
knew at that moment that he was not
going to cross did he know that i don't
think he knew that when he took the job
and that's why i think you're right i i
i question
sincerely
whether if uh if if nick casario knew
everything
about this situation whether he would
have taken this job
well
but he knew easter b
and i think that's the key and i've
realized over the course of the past
several months there are two distinct
camps
among folks in the nfl and i don't know
how big
each one is but one camp consists of the
people
who
are charmed by easter bee
and the other camp
and i think there are more in this camp
peter consists of the people who think
he's a snake oil salesman a charlatan a
bs artist an opportunist a climber
anything but someone who has the chops
to get it done he just wants the money
the title the power without the ability
to actually deserve it and wield it and
he talks a good game and it's all a
bunch of crap that's the other camp two
camps cacerio is clearly in the first
camp regardless of who else is in that
first camp cal mcnair and nick casario
may be the only two members of that club
but caserio doesn't take that job
if he doesn't think easter b
is
legitimately qualified on the up and up
not a snake oil salesman not a charlatan
not a bs artist there's no way caserio
takes that job and if he does take that
job and he thinks those things then it's
on him
i think that
nick casario knew jack easter be in a
different time and place
and i think that especially
you know with jack easter be saying to
nick casario
i do not want to be the general manager
i've never wanted to be the general
manager you are going to come in with
full general manager authority cal
mcnair says to him jack easter b's not
the general manager i'm never going to
make him the general manager never going
to give him personnel authority you have
personnel authority on this team you
will have the biggest say the biggest
voice in who our head coach is going to
be in fact
when uh brandon staley interviewed for
this job on the morning he interviewed
at uh
8 30 or not 9 30 in the morning pacific
time
uh for this job before he got in his car
and went down to uh talk to the chargers
at which point later in the day he got
the charger job
but when he was interviewing with
caserio it was casario alone
and it was cassari the understanding was
this was going to be casario's hire the
recommendation
uh the guy who he wanted was going to
get approved by the ownership of this
team
and so to me mike
i think nick casario thought that he was
coming into a situation where he was
going to have full personnel authority
and control
and which i still think is going to
happen
and he had no idea at that time
that deshaun watson had told the owner
of this team uh i i'm not
or told anybody with this team that i am
absolutely not coming back
there were people in new england who had
heard and who believed that easter b had
aspirations to be a general manager at
some point remember when bill belichick
did the press conference in advance of
the new england game against houston
during football season after the easter
bee stuff first was kicked up belichick
had that quote about easter b he's not a
personnel person no my understanding is
that that part of that came from
this vibe that was prevailing in new
england that easter be had these
unrealistic aspirations
to go from chaplain with the chiefs
unpaid
a decade ago or less than that into
actually being a general manager of a
team someday that there were people in
new england who knew it apparently
caserio didn't or he wasn't troubled by
it wasn't bothered by it wasn't
threatened by the possibility and
speaking of easter bee he came up
yesterday during kali's press conference
let's hear kali explain
exactly what it is
that easter bee does serious
i'm the head coach
jack is uh he's vice president of
football operations which involves a
bunch of things that involves scheduling
uh it involves logistics around the
building it involves uh a bunch of
things that that that go on here that
that he does a wonderful job of doing
and and basically uh it's a multitude of
responsibilities
okay as far as personnel
uh
general manager is nick nick hannah's
all personnel
that's what kelly had to say but a
multitude of responsibilities for
jackie's to be apparently not putting
the toothpaste back in the tube after he
saw what cully had to say to jim trotter
and steve weish but multitude of
responsibilities
uh without a whole lot of specifics but
that you know kind of meshes with the
sense that easter bee's got his hand in
a lot of different things and he's got
the blessing of cal mcnair so you know
who knows how far it goes peter he
continues to be this mysterious figure
even though he's gotten far more
notoriety than he ever bargained for
we still don't really know what the
guy's doing but we know he's involved in
a lot of things a multitude of things as
kelly would say
yeah i did a story last uh august mike
on
a day in the life of an nfl team at
training camp in this weird weird year
and for that story
i had access to easter bee i talked to
him three or four times that day
and i also got to witness
one of his
big duties with the organization and one
of those big duties was at the end of
the day
he had a half hour session where all the
department heads reviewed what happened
that day
what the issues were
were there any coveted related problems
were there any testing problems anything
like that and then looking forward to
the next day
with you know who had this job who had
that job and bill o'brien sat in the
audience
for that meeting you know
there was no question that jack easterby
was sort of setting the daily schedule
you know which i'm sure because after
this meeting he met with bill o'brien to
talk about
those kind of things one-on-one
so i'm sure it was at o'brien's
uh you know it was it was in o'brien's
purview to say jack this is your job i
need to now go coach the football team
you handle all of these details
and in training camp during the time of
covid there were a thousand details
every day
and so
that is you know to me
in the time of covid the vice president
of football operations has a lot to do
and mike i would disagree with you on
this i just don't think i don't think
there's any evidence inside the texans
that jack easterby ever said or ever
moved to become the general manager of
this team i think you can say a lot of
negative things about him but i don't
think and i don't think it was ever a
serious consideration if indeed he ever
did a thing about it that cal mcnair
would have made him the general manager
he was the interim general manager peter
he had the job right but that was the
guy all it was
he was he was a placeholder that's all
he was to be a general manager he was
never going to be the general manager of
this team
i think he had aspirations to be and at
the time that this all happened that's
when people especially in houston in the
houston media and the fans you know the
fans ordinarily don't care about this
kind of stuff it's been amazing to me
how the texans fans
have had the alarms go off and the red
flags go up with easter b
i don't think he expected the kind of
scrutiny and blowback
that he got as he reached closer and
closer for that brass ring
and the blowback resulted in guys like
cal mcnair saying he's never going to be
the general manager of this team that
doesn't mean he didn't have the
aspiration it just means it got smacked
down it got ripped out of his hand
because he climbed too fast
and people started to say who the hell
is this guy and why is he climbing and
that was at the same time peter
questions were coming up about his
resume an embellishment of his
background and overstating of whatever
limited experience and it's extremely
limited in football operations that's
when this all kind of came together so
what happened was
he was getting closer and closer to
pulling it off
and it blew up on him i firmly believe
that
yeah i don't and i think that his
biggest mistake and the team's biggest
mistake right now quite honestly
when jenny verentis and greg bishop of
sports illustrated had that story
uh a few months ago about you know how
disastrous his past and what was going
on inside the team was
you know for him not
to talk
publicly for that story and not to
refute
whatever it was in that story that he
felt should have been refuted
a it leads you to believe that uh
you know to me the team was setting him
up to be the fall guy
or b
that uh that they just made a terrible
mistake in not allowing easter bee to
defend himself and i'm assuming that he
wanted to defend himself i don't know
that but i'm assuming who would want to
have a story written about them that
said a you're a con artist or whatever
and i'm exaggerating that but but in
essence that was an extremely negative
story about easter bee
uh and
not to say that it was a bad story i
think it was a good story
but it was an extremely negative story
about easter bee
and he should have spoken up and said
something about it why do you not defend
yourself
in an august publication with two
excellent journalists like that i i
think it's
i think it was ridiculous
well peter maybe it's because you are a
con artist and the jig is up maybe
that's why you got nothing to say and
you just keep your head low and you do
everything short of calling the press
the enemy of the people it's that simple
that's kind of what con artists do and
we've witnessed that in other contexts
over the past few years and thank god
we're not dealing with that anymore on a
broader level and that's all i'm going
to say about that
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports